[Music]
we couldn't get enough of him so we
brought him back joining us once more is
Kelsey Hightower developer advocate at
Google cloud Kelsey talk to us about how
civil solutions help developers yes I
think several the solutions for people
new to server lists it's kind of like
we've learned a lot of patterns from
four or five years of kubernetes and all
the things you need to do to provide
that higher-level interface that you
give all your developers or that you
enjoy working with every day
that's where service attempts to start
so we take some of those patterns and we
give people the smallest interface that
they want to do so if you think about if
I file gets uploaded to a google cloud
storage bucket you can just invoke your
business logic and execute your code for
you now people wants to relist but they
also want containers how is Google
enabling developers to have both the
velocity of serverless
and the flexibility of containers that's
the thing that I'm probably the most
proud of so when server list is most
introduced for first introduced to most
people they always thought about it as
functions as a service you write a
single function and event comes in it
calls your function but there's a lot of
existing business logic that needs a
little bit more than just a single
function we've there's some
bootstrapping code you gotta set up
things like logging but a little bit
more flexibility and your choice at
runtime so what we decided to do was
take a lot of the learnings from
kubernetes and allow developers to
deploy their own docker containers so
any runtime that you want to use any
business logic that you want any
libraries and we're going to execute
that container just like we do with our
cloud functions so they scale to zero
they scale up quick and they give you
the same service workflow that you used
to without abandoning all the good
things that come with containers yes
you've talked a little bit about you
know service isn't brand new but we're
changing the way that we're sort of
approaching it can you can you tell us a
little bit more about how Google is
changing that service experience so I
think for us is that our DNA has always
been around this idea of this kind of
software delivery chain right so this
idea that when you build a software we
like to build it once we sign those
images and then we decide where we want
them to be deployed so that means giving
people a bit of choice so typically
service has been kind of these
proprietary cloud platforms once you're
in there you're kind of locked in what
we decided to do is make sure that it
runs everywhere so wherever you as
developer want to run just like most
Google tools and libraries we allow our
serve list ax to run wherever you are so
I think what we're doing different here
is taking some of the things that worked
well in the kubernetes space and combine
them with some of the developer
experiences that we know that people are
looking for and just combining the two
so flexibility without the without
losing the trade-offs and benefits of
going server list that's great so how
does server list our service offering
help our developers and how is it
different I think where it's different
is that you get to use a familiar tool
chain that has been popularized over the
last couple of years right so containers
are the way most people think about
having full control over their own
software then to be able to take that
software and outsource all of the
delivery right so security I am
integration being able to connect to
things like spanner and bigquery taking
all of that kind of toil away from you
and just say hey check in your
containers and we'll run them for you so
what we're trying to do is kind of make
it very seamless from a developer once
you go from idea to deployed we're just
trying to give you that same GCP
experience at the container level nice
now how do I service offerings give
developers a more open and portable
offering so that customers can
potentially move their workloads around
so one thing the trend that has been
really prevalent in GCP is in kubernetes
we started with docker popular open
source container runtime and then we
shipped an open source project
kubernetes which is the underlying
platform for gke and then when we
thought about entering servlet so we've
had App Engine for it for almost 11
years now and we decided that let's what
would we do we wanted to make App Engine
be more open so we decided to start with
the K native project so K native has a
lot of service component you can think
of as a service toolkit things like
builds a function framework and most of
that stuff is laid on top of kubernetes
so what we've done is we took in the
best parts of kubernetes again those
design patterns that we talked about how
do I just run my application we've
restricted that out into a high level
set of libraries called K native and
there's a hosted version we call cloud
run and we also give you the ability to
run cloud run on top of gke so the
benefit there is that if you need to do
some machine learning you can take that
service work load and run on a
specialized VM with a GPU or TPU so
you're no longer restricted to our just
our service runtime environments you now
have the whole of GCP opened up to you
even in the service context you touched
on this a bit but a lot of our customers
tell us that they have customer
requirements like specific runtimes
custom binaries or workload portability
and more often than not they turn to
containers for an answer can you talk
about how our gke serverless add-on
allows you to bring serverless to
containers yes when you think about a
lot of these abstractions change over
time we went from mainframe to physical
machines to virtualization to
higher-level platforms like App Engine
what we now have with the container
image this ability to build a code that
you want use the runtime that you want
any version that you want and now that
becomes a portable bit you can run this
on a virtual machine you can run this on
gke
you can run this on cloud run and you
can also run it on App Engine so I think
what a developer gets is this ability to
truly write once and deploy wherever
they want now well we believe Google
Cloud is a great place to run old types
of workloads some customers we know that
they need to run on-premises or across
multiple clouds right so tell us about a
little bit more about Kay native and its
role in giving developers the freedom to
move stateless containers pretty much
anywhere yeah so our contribution to the
ecosystem started with maybe kubernetes
right so kubernetes over the four or
five years you can see it now it's
deployed and offered by every major
cloud provider lots of people are
already running it on Prem so it has a
wide adoption so our strategy of
layering Kay native on top of kubernetes
this allows us to kind of reap those
benefits so the tools that you're
familiar with we lay our key native on
top so that gives us that portability
framework underneath so no matter where
you're running whether it's on Prem
different cloud provider on GCP you can
get the same API is right so we talked
earlier about automating those api's
that's what kubernetes represents and
I've always set discrimination as a
platform for building platforms and
we've chosen to build our newest
serverless platforms on top of
kubernetes can you talk a little bit
more about how Canada provides eventing
and integrating events from Google or
third-party services so you can really
extend your applications so the big
thing to know about key native is not
just Google's project right so now we
have so many contributors you know Red
Hat Cloud Foundry so a lot of the things
that we've seen in the eventing space
like what is an event how should we
accept it I'll have those open protocols
like cloud events all of that supported
inside
so Keita NATO gives you a couple of
components we call K native serving run
my container skillet 2-0 started again
when a request comes in then you have
the event team piece so there's an event
and what we wanted to do is make event
portable so different cloud providers
has a different collection of events
different transports for events so we
wanted to do is make sure that the event
framework was very flexible if you want
to integrate with github or GCP or one
of some other service that you have that
you defined yourself that's also
included so what we've done is we given
all of these framework pieces and what
we've done with cloud run is we've kind
of curated the perfect stack for you
great and is there a particular way in
which we were able to solve that problem
that you described of like having all of
these things leave in all of these
different places yes I think for us is
kubernetes is super flexible so what
that flexibility allows every cloud
provider to do their own integration for
example arm Prem we come out of the gate
integrating with things like with VMware
and f5 so we abstract away some of the
differences between all of these
platforms so that's what kubernetes is
job is once you have that set of
abstractions things like Kay native just
sit on top and ieave leus oom that those
abstractions are there and then we can
get on with building those higher-level
platforms so Cooper days is a huge part
of this and the community has been doing
this work for over four years abstract
in the way the differences between these
cloud providers so whenever you build on
top of that we just inherit all of those
benefits well thank you so much again
for joining us today Kelsey awesome
thanks for having me
[Music]